KYLE KEANE: So today,
we're going to do something
where we talk about our name.
Renew icebreakery
thing for like 15--
well, no, there's
a lot of people--
20 minutes.
Name, what brought you here.
And, oh yeah, right off the bat
I'll say the more you all talk,
the less I talk.
So you'll get sick of
my voice, I promise.
I am very monotonous at times.
And so, the more you guys
participate by saying words,
the less you have
to hear my voice.
So I would like three
things that we would
like to know about each other.
So if you could say--
I need three more bullet
points about things
that we're going to say.
This is the moment
where you talk,
otherwise I just
have a compulsion.
I want to hear my
voice constantly,
that's why I'm in
front of a classroom.
AUDIENCE: Favorite video game.
KYLE KEANE: Favorite video game.
Cool.
Oh, that's so well-themed.
Nice.
All right.
No, honestly.
We had one-handed food during
the seminar I was teaching,
but, yeah, favorite video
game is really on point.
I can write, I promise.
There we go.
All right, favorite video game.
I can do this.
AUDIENCE: Programming
background?
KYLE KEANE: Programming
background, sure.
Do we want to know
languages or--
AUDIENCE: Either languages,
amount of rough--
amount of experience.
Things like that.
KYLE KEANE: All right.
So something about your
general level of experience.
And if you have nothing
to say about that,
then just say [INAUDIBLE]--
and that's perfectly fine.
That gives us a good read
on what's happening there.
One more bullet point.
Are these called bullet
points when they're dashes?
Maybe they're just
called dashes.
AUDIENCE: Close enough.
KYLE KEANE: Falsima, was it?
KYLE KEANE: Close enough.
Oh, yes, that's good.
AUDIENCE: You can call them
bullets-- squashed bullets.
KYLE KEANE: Squashed bullets--
I like that.
All right.
One more fun thing.
AUDIENCE: How about what
you might do with Unity?
KYLE KEANE: Cool.
All right.
What do you want to do?
Well, if you think that
that's different than what
brought you here.
AUDIENCE: All
right, fair enough.
KYLE KEANE: Yeah.
All right.
I like it, but all right, so--
the vision for the type of game.
Because some of you may
have come with this,
oh my god, I have this
amazing side scroller
that involves pajamas
and bed sheets.
So you can feel free
to share that here.
What type of game or
what you want to do.
I know that it's way too
small, but that's all right.
We'll get it from example,
once each other starts sharing.
AUDIENCE: Where you're from.
KYLE KEANE: Where you're from--
I love that one.
There's so many fun things--
I'm from Southern California.
And when I was in
Southern California,
most people were from
Southern California.
But now that I am in
Cambridge, I get so excited.
I'm like, that person--
I had a freshman in
my seminar this year
that was from my neighboring
city in Southern California.
It was so exciting.
All right.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KYLE KEANE: It is Chino
Hills, California,
which is a tiny weird little
city that is not really
connected to many other cities.
AUDIENCE: Near LA, I'm guessing.
KYLE KEANE: It's
in-between LA and San
Diego and out into the desert.